All living things are made out of cells.
Every cell is surrounded by a thin film
called a membrane, stuffed with the
machinery and instructions for life.
Cells come in a huge variety of shapes
and sizes. Every cell excels at a
particular job.
Different cells have different
structures. Bacteria and plant cells
have a tough wall surrounding them, but
our cells don't. Our cells have smaller
containers inside, called organelles,
while bacteria don't.
Most living things can exist as just a
single cell, like bacteria or amoeba,
but animals and plants are formed from
many cells stuck together. Cells are
often very small. Most bacteria are
100,000 times smaller than a grain of
rice. Some of our cells are much larger.
Our neurons can reach from our heads to
our toes.
Shape is very important for cells.
Neurons allow our brains to tell our
toes how to move, so they are long and
narrow like wires. Bacteria need to
move around, so they have tiny
propellers that allow them to swim.
Trillions of small cells can make a
majestic narwhal, a beating heart, and
a kitten's nose. We start as a single
cell, which splits into two, then four,
then eight and so on, until some cells
specialize to become your gut, your
brain and all other parts of your body.
Some cells can crawl. Some can transmit
electricity. Some cells can eat other
cells. Some cells can capture sunlight.
Some can glow. What other different
types of cells can you think of? How do
their unique shapes and sizes help them
perform their jobs?